this is joint worked with Dan Ellis DARS
Jim asked miss ruddy and Kailash filly
and Jimmy Mizzou okay so the consensus
problem is one of the most studied
problems of theory distributed computing
and in this problem every process piece
of virus is a private input value X if I
and each process the doesn't crash must
output a value after taking a finite
number of steps that's called wait for
each rumination and these values have to
satisfy two properties one is agreement
that all output values are the same okay
so they all agree they had come to
consensus and secondly the output value
of each process is the input value of
some process so you can't just sort of
say well we'll always decides here and
hence will always agree no matter what
it inputs are hitting the bootcamp I
prove that consensus is impossible in a
synchronous system of two or more
processes that only communicate using
reads and writes okay and I used a
valency argument and I'm not going to go
over in great detail here and just a
configuration is X unified you know feel
it if all executions starting from
configuration C output X and the
configuration see is violent if there
are two executions starting from C then
output different values and the way the
proof works is to prove two lemmas the
first is that every consensus algorithm
has a bivalent initial configuration and
the second limit is that from every
violent configuration there's a step
that leads to a bivalent configuration
now in a binary configuration obviously
no process can have terminated because
then there can't be another execution if
a process is terminated with value 0
there can't be some execution from that
configuration where a process inputs one
or the protocol be incorrect so putting
these two lemmas together this implies
that there's an infinite execution
consisting of only bivalent
configurations which violates weight
freedom now we call such a proof
extension bastes or at least informally
okay I also at the end of my table
bootcamp talk talked about the case at
agreement problem and this is a
generalization of consensus of the case
K equals one is consensus problem and in
this problem we have the same inputs and
we still have weight free termination
and similarly validity each the output
of each processes the input of some
process but we also have the agreement
property is a little bit more relaxed it
says that there are most K different
values that are output so we are now and
the input values come from 0 to K
instead of 0 0 or 1 so what we want to
agree on there all the process 1/2
degree on most K different of and most K
different values so they can't output
all there's no execution in which all K
plus 1 values are output
now he's in agreement it's also
impossible in asynchronous systems with
more than K processes that communicate
using read and write registers the first
proofs of this result came ten years
after the proof of the impossibility of
consensus and including done by a
variety of authors including Mike and
they all use some form of topological
arguments and a national question is
whether this result has an extension
based proof okay
the those the proposed proofs were very
complicated okay and what I'm going to
talk it's showing this a talk is that
the answer to that question is no it's
not possible to get an extension based
proof of the impossibility of case in
agreement so if they don't lend if my
talk is as follows I'm gonna start with
the model of computation which is going
to seem a little strange but it's
because we need it for the second part
and that'll be a topological view of a
protocol in this model then I'll define
formally what I mean by an extension
based proof and if we have time I'll
prove that there's no extension based
proof of the impossibility of KSAT
agreement for more than K processes
obviously if there's like a or less
fewer processes they can agree on K
values okay so the model we're going to
use is the non-uniform iterated
immediate snapshot model which I'm never
gonna say again and I'll call it ni is
and this was introduced by Kristin
Shadid in 1999 and in this model they're
in processes about the north and p 0 to
P n minus 1 and the processes are going
to communicate using an infant sequence
of snapshot objects and each snapshot
object is going to have n components
which are all initially bottom and in a
snapshot object processing a process I
can update component I and it can also
perform a scan which gives the value I
have vector R returning the value of all
the components atomically ok so initial
API state is its input in any such in
this model and in its first FBI updates
component I of s1 would stay
so just rights at stake that's all it's
allowed to do and in this next step it
does scan to get the values of all and
components and it updates a state to be
the value of this vector that gets back
and the next time it's allocated the
step P I updates component I of s2 with
its state okay and then the next time
it's going to perform next step it
performs a scan to Tomic Li it scans all
of s2 and gets all of the values that
couldn't update all the components that
have been updated okay
and that becomes its new state so it's a
very boring kind of protocol although
this is one kind of protocol
well actually we also have to talk about
when processes terminate no put and so
there's a decision function Delta that
map's each process state to either an
output value or the special symbol
bottom so if Delta maps a pair
consisting of process in that state to
some value Y which is not bottom then we
say that process P I outputs Y in state
s and terminates okay and if Delta maps
that pair to bottom this indicates the
PI hasn't yet decided when it's in state
s okay and a protocol for a task the ni
a s model is completely specified by its
decision function Delta so essentially
you can think of this as a full
information we protocol to that you're
just sort of everything you know you
write and then you see read everything
that you are you're allowed to read and
then you update your state with that and
when you update stuff you you update
with everything you know etc and then
the only thing we have to specify is you
know in your current state with what
you've seen all for your history what
you decide win okay so all right now the
order in which processes take steps this
is fun decided by it an adversarial
scheduler in other words protocol is
correct only if it's correct under any
of ordering now the APIs aerial
scheduler is actually going to work in a
particular way it's going to repeatedly
select a set of processes that are all
poised to perform updates in the same
snapshot object okay and
it'll schedule all of these updates and
then schedule all through next scans
okay so that's when so for example what
we might this is an example of a
schedule so the adversarial scheduler
selected these three processes 0 1 & 2
and so each of those is going to perform
an update on the snapshot object s1 and
then they will sit and then they'll all
perform scan so they'll all see the
inputs of one another
ok so p0 p1 and p2 will see the inputs
of p0 p1 and p2 then the scheduler
suppose schedules the set piece chooses
to set P 3 P 6 ok so then then there
they're going to perform updates on a
snapshot object s1 and then when they
perform their scans which is going to
happen next they'll not only see their
values but they'll also see the values
of p0 p1 and p2
ok now if we schedule pizza if the p2 is
scheduled next then it's going to
perform an update on atomic snapshot s2
and so the result of that is only going
to be its own what it saw its own value
because nobody else the other process
has updated process performed an update
and snap shut up s2 and then finally if
p4 and p5 take steps are scheduled that
set then they're gonna perform updates
on snapshot object 1 ok because it's
there their first steps ok and then
they'll do a then they'll do a scan and
they'll see the first value is written
by p0 p1 p2 p3 56 p4 and p5 ok so that
it's a it's a little bit of a bizarre
model writing each of them know what
this is
asynchronous something yeah it's
asynchronous and so it's it's iterated
because we do differ
um we're iterated this because you're
doing it on different snapshot objects
as you're going along so it's just it's
a very I mean one would never want to
write programs in this model but for
analyzing lower bounds it should because
it has all this full information kind of
stuff in it just makes it easier to work
with
ok
now lots of generality the scheduler can
schedule all operations on s1 before all
any operation and s2 in all operations
and it's - before any operations is an
s3 basically what we have is that we can
in particular if we had this execution
here that's indistinguishable from the
set execution here where p4 and p5
perform their updates and s1 before
process p2 performs it up update on s2
and this is because operations on
different snapshot objects can commute
with one another in the sense that it's
indistinguishable Denny processes which
one of those two operations took place
first hey because there's there their
complete staff shot object is starting
fresh okay so we're gonna have that nice
normal form it'll be useful for us okay
in this model the configuration consists
of the state of each process and the
contents of each snapshot object at some
point in the schedule okay and if a
process is not terminated but it's not
subsequently scheduled for example yes
then the process is considered to have
crashed and we see that a process is
activated if it is not terminated or
crashed
now this one the reason we can talk
about such a world weird well it's a
hostess ravit
proof that this model is computationally
equivalent to the standard asynchronous
shared memory model which processes
communicate by reading from and writing
to shared registers so we're back to
what we really want to talk about just
we have this more convenient thing to
work with so it's much easier to use
tools from combinatorial topology in
this model and when I say that it's
equivalent I mean that a task that can
be solved by weight free protocol and
one of these models can be solved by
weight pre protocol in the other so
that's what we mean they're equivalent
so if I prove a lower band in the NIS
model an impossibility result in the NI
is model I also have proved an
impossibility result in the asynchronous
shared memory model with processes
community communicating by reads and
writes okay so that's our that's our
model okay now I have to give you a
little bit about combinatorial topology
I'm gonna get this is the slide of a
combinatorial topology and so we don't
really have to knew too much more okay
so a simplicial complex Sigma is a
collection of sets that's closed under
subset ie if X is an element of Sigma
and Y is the subset of X then Y is an
element of Sigma okay and in topology is
set in Sigma is called a simplex okay
and I said in a simplicial complex is
called a simplex and a simplex of size 1
is going to be called a vertex and a
simplex of size 2 is called the neck
okay and so for example here if we look
at this triangle here okay that's that's
a simplex of size 3 and the edges in
that triangle this one here that one
here and that one there those are three
different simplices three different
edges three different simplices of size
two
okay
so um okay so we want to look at how do
we represent a configuration in this
topological view so each vertex is going
to represent a process and a state of
that process so the process is going to
be denoted by a color so we in this
picture I have three different processes
the black one the white one and the red
one and the state of that process which
is denoted by a label inside so in this
case what I have is here this is the red
process and it happens to be in state
one okay now a reachable configuration
is represented by the set of vertices
corresponding to the processes that have
not crashed the C in the state of those
processes and C so I have a
configuration and I look at the state of
each process in that configuration so
the red process may have value zero the
white process may have value one and the
black process may have thought you zero
that's a configuration okay and that
particular simplex that said it's ice
three notes like that configuration okay
so it's just a convenient way of being
able to talk about these things and the
input complex represents all initial
configurations so this is part of the
input complex for to set agreement
amongst three processes so there are
three processes the white the red and
black and each of them can have input
values 0 1 or 2 now so I have all the
possible vertices of this the problem is
this they're a lot more inches and a lot
more sense of size 3 that I haven't
shown ok so there just so you sort of
this is a way of looking at algorithms
in the NAIS model ok so what you haven't
quite seen protocol yet ok so now we
want to look at a protocol
so the simplicial complex of a protocol
is the set of all reachable
configurations the protocol in which no
processes are active so particularly
we're looking all they can figure it
reachable configurations in which every
process is either terminated or crashed
ok we call that protocol is wheat-free
if every process terminates after being
scheduled a finite number of times
and the simplicial complex of a
wheat-free protocol in the NIS model has
a very special structure which we're
going to use in our proofs ok so I know
I have to describe that in order to do
that I actually have to introduce a
little bit more notation a little bit
more from from topology ok so I want to
talk about the chromatic subdivision of
a simplex ok so here is my so here we
have a simplex representing a
configuration reached by a schedule in
which every active process has been
selected the same number of times
ok and let's consider all schedules from
this configuration in which every active
process is selected most once so this is
my original configuration and I want to
I'm representing that by some some
triangle and this is the set of
resulting configuration so all possible
things I can get by scheduling each of
the product the white red and black
process each at most once ok
it's actually this ok I can represent it
that way so let me just what's going on
here okay so if process X I said the
white process perfectly is scheduled
first by itself
ok they're all poised on the same
snapshot object which is all initially
empty okay so if it's scheduled all by
itself first then what would it sees
it's just it sees its own input value X
ok but now let's suppose that X Y and I
think the white and the red and the
black processes are all scheduled
together ok as the first this step so
what happens will been they all right
there update their components with x y&z
and when they do perform their scans
they each of them they see XY and Z ok
and so these are sort of listing all the
possible things that can happen when a
process went the way the processes are
scheduled ok so we can have one process
going first a pair of processes being
scheduled first etc ok it has this very
nice this nice structure ok it's I don't
want to draw it with more than
because then it was much more ugly all
right least harder for me to draw okay
so in this case we haven't had we have
no processes that have crashed okay and
that's what happens now we also have a
chromatic subdivision of a simplex when
there's a process that's terminated okay
so here we have a process that's
terminated this white process is
terminated then it's not going to take
any more steps so it what's gonna happen
is it's always gonna stay here okay and
so then we don't have there's not going
to be other things in here and if this
process that the white process is never
going to be right writing to the
snapshot object okay so the red and
black processes are never going to see
anything then it writes and so in
particular these are the only possible
things that we have so there's a sort of
the geometric view of what's happening
but you can do it okay so the
non-uniform chromatic subdivision of the
simplicial complex is obtained by
replacing every setna simplicial complex
by its chromatic subdivision so we have
all the simplicial complex consists of a
bunch of these different triangles all
connected together in weird ways and
what we do is chromatically subdivide
each of them in its non uniform because
sometimes there's thing and some
vertices that have terminated and so we
do different things and those in those
in those triangles than one's worth
there's all of them have there's no
processes terminated okay so that's what
we do all right so we're gonna so we're
lecture not be the input input
simplicial complex for protocol in the
NAIS model and we'll let you want to be
did non-uniform chromatic subdivision
look you know it okay and then k one
will represent all configurations the
protocol reachable from an initial
configuration by schedule in which each
active process is selected exactly once
okay so the guy we have a nice view of
what's happening
okay well we can repeat this okay so for
any R we let Q R plus one denote the non
uniform chromatic subdivision of Q R so
we have Q 0 Q 1 Q 2 Q etc and so Q R
plus 1 represents all configurations to
the protocol reachable from a
configuration and Q R by scheduling in
which each active process is selected
exactly once and if we have a protocol
in the any is model in which every
process terminates after it's been
selected in most our times then Q R is a
simplicial complex of the protocol
specified by this decision map Delta
okay so we have a for any member in the
na s model a protocol is just specified
by the decision map otherwise everything
is is exactly the same because some
processes can crash
oh I think the only reason if it's
crashes yes of crisis yeah yeah okay
okay they're a couple of properties of
this and I put them on the board and I'm
not gonna prove them because I clearly
don't have time but essentially what we
have if we have some sort of path in
here okay in and QR and we had been if
we want to go from here to here in QR
plus 1 the distance is going to expand
okay
and the point is well if something is
has terminated
well these edges are these blue edges
here are going to be the same as here
but if in here we these are between
pairs of unterminated vertices okay that
haven't terminated then when we do the
chromatic subdivision okay to get from
here to here it's going to take at least
two okay and similarly to get from here
to here well in this case it's much more
than two but it would take it at least
two to get there and so we we have a
lemma that basically says if I have if I
can tell you that these two pieces of
disjoint pieces sub complexes of QR are
for our part and if I chromatically
subdivide the whole thing then they're
gonna be even farther apart okay that's
that's what I want to say okay two other
ulemas so suppose I have a simplex a
little triangle and Q F and F is the
largest sub complex of Q which contains
only vertices their distance at most one
from every vertex in F okay so with this
little triangle I look at the things
that the vertices their distance and
most of including it that that's the
vertices is that simplex and all the
vertices their distance at most one from
every vertex in F okay then I claim that
there exists an input value a okay such
at every vertex and F contains a so
there's some value that's seen by
everybody in in this little piece okay
it might be that if we're somehow in the
middle of things everybody's everybody's
seen every input value but if we happen
to be starting off let's say we're
there's the all zero inputs all the
inputs are zero
okay then well they're certainly
everybody else seems zero and everything
around it everybody will see zero so
sort of that anyhow we can prove that
and this basically says well if this is
true for some sub complex then when we
do the subdivision it remains true okay
so I don't have a boat and look I guess
about ten minutes laughter the airboats
and so it gives me a little bit of time
to tell you what an extension based
proof is okay and so this is why it's in
an interactive interactive complex the
workshop so an extension based proof is
represented as an interaction between
approver in a protocol which is defined
by some math Delta okay initially the
proofer only knows the initial
configurations of the protocol and where
the state of each process is its input
and will let a1 denote the set of those
configurations and we're gonna define a
1 prime to be initialized to the empty
set and what we're not allowed to do
allow is the proofer can repeatedly
query the protocol by choosing a
configuration either one of the initial
configurations a1 or something that it
that it gets its put into a1 prime so
things that it's already explored and
it's like a set of processes and PE
they're all performed all right poised
to perform an update of the same
snapshot object and see ok so it's sort
of playing the role of the scheduler
it's saying ok here's a configuration I
know something about and I want to see
what happens when this set of processes
which are all poised to update the same
snapshot object are now going to be
scheduled and this have to be all of
them it just has to be a subset of them
ok so it could be just one processor it
could be two processes that are all that
are both poised to to update snapshot
object 17 ok and then what the the
protocol has to respond with is the
state it has to respond with the state
of each of those processes and the
resulting configuration so what happens
when the those processes take steps ok
so well the states are pretty are
well-defined ok
from the NIS protocol this is full
information so it's just all the
information there but what we actually
what it has to do is actually
tell us what the value of the decision
function is when we get there okay
so that's that's what it has to do so
that's it's basically performing these
queries the proofer is getting the
information about the protocol okay or
about the decision function Delta okay
so once it does that it for each of the
process that took a step the protocol
tells us what the weather the the
process is stopped or or is still
continuing if it stopped what it would
value eight outputs okay that's what
it's doing and then what happens is as C
prime this new configuration we get it
gets added to a one prime and we could
be proved or can then start from there
or can the continue from from C or some
other initial configuration so it just
can ask these individual sort of
starting from some initial
configurations to get this tree of
configurations that it's query it gets
more and more information about okay and
the peripheral wins namely it shows that
the protocol is incorrect it's a
protocol response and consistently so it
says a process gives two different
responses for delta for the same process
in the same state it responds with more
than k different outputs in some
configuration or with an output in a
configuration which is obtained by
scheduled from an initial configuration
in which no process at a and its input
and this would violate the Lavi this is
this one would violate the agreement
property okay but this is not very
interesting okay this model so if the
proofer could only make a finite number
of queries the protocol con always
respond with bottom okay and if the
protocol then the only thing that they
prove or could do to show that the
protocol is it's never found anything
inconsistent so it could just claim
moose who's not weight free but in the
protocol could say but you know if you
just asked one more query I think the
processes would have stopped okay so
this isn't interesting so we have to add
one more kind of query so we're going to
allow actually the
prepare to make a chain of queries such
that C 0 p 0 C 1 P 1 etc such that for
each I greater equal 0 CI plus 1 is the
configuration resulting from scheduling
product the set of processes P I and
configuration CI and if the protocol
does not eventually terminate all of the
processes in the chain ok then the
prover wins since the protocols not wait
Freitas has constructed this infinite
execution ok but the protocol presumably
is not going to do that so after making
finitely many chains of queries without
winning the prover must choose a
configure the the proofer service has
sort of exhausted itself and it must
choose a configuration seeing a a 1
prime and to find a 2 to be the set of
all configurations that are essentially
that are the same as SC except that the
4 processes that haven't taken any steps
yet we can give them any input ok so
that's we're doing if it's if P is an
initial state then we can change what an
initial value it has because it hasn't
done anything yet but if it's not an
initial State we've sort of fixed it ok
and so basically this is just it's it's
really committing to a schedule
so the approvers committing to a
schedule and it'll only query about
configurations that are reached and
reachable from extensions of that
schedule so that's where um that's what
we're doing so that's really the notion
of an extension ok
and so the proofer were the protocol so
the prover wins of the protocol in the
same way before if it's inconsistent has
is incorrect either of these two ways or
if it asks an infinite chain of queries
or if there's an infinite number of
phases ok so if it can keep on asking
phases and keep on doing this then we
say the prover wins and the prover loses
if at the end of some phase
there was nothing it didn't it couldn't
ask any more queries because all of the
processes in that configuration had
terminated
Hey so that's an extension priests proof
and now in the last few minutes I'm
gonna give you a very very high-level a
quick view of why there's no extension
base proof through the install mobility
of KSAT agreement so to prove that case
that agreement is unsolvable using an
extension based proof or proof from us
win against every protocol okay that's
it so to show there's no extension base
proof what we're going to do is give it
an adversarial protocol that is
adaptively constructed in Mac Delta and
show that every prove our losses against
this protocol so it's a little bit of a
flip of the usual adversary argument so
I'm going to construct this strategy
initially I'm just going to start with
the input of complex and for I'm going
to chromatically subdivide three times
and well I guess I can at least
subdivide four times and in the first
three after the in in the first three
times everything's just going to be a
bottom I'm not gonna have any process
stop because this is my protocol I don't
want things to stop too early and in um
thank you for if if I have enough vertex
that only has one one input value hasn't
seen anything else besides it's only
input value then it's going to output
the value a and terminate you know put
the value eight other arises and well
maintain a bunch of invariance which are
here that I'm not gonna have time to go
through and essentially what I'm gonna
do is I'm going at each time there's a
query I'm going to specify more and more
of what happens in Delta okay and the
point is I'm going to do it in such a
this is just in this first particular in
the first phase and we're doing such a
way that
the the places where I have things that
are defined
okay so there's outputs in various
places those are going to be for our
parts
okay and what I can do if they're not
quite far enough apart then I can do
some additional chromatic subdivisions
and they'll be even farther apart by
this by this stuff here okay um yeah oh
yeah I don't really have much time so we
do this for phase one and then at the
end of phase one oh I have to show that
during phase one there's no offended
change okay because things go far enough
apart and I can define things in
appropriate way in which I wrote down
there but don't have time to talk about
and then at the beginning of Phase two
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
look at what the extension is that the
approver pecs and then I what I want to
do is basically find a value and knot
right there at that configuration but a
little bit farther out okay sort of to
the extent of where the the approver is
explored so far we'd go up that far and
then at that point I'm gonna define
everything to have that basically I'm
gonna fill in everything so everything
is terminated just what not in the
entire complex but just admit the things
that are reachable from the extension
that the that the prover fixed on okay
so it has an extension and I'm sure
within that extension I can always do
that okay and okay and so basically I'm
going to show that there's no infinite
chains and the prover must eventually
choose a configuration at the end of
some phase in which everything every
vertex is terminated and hence that
means that the prover is going to lose
okay so we we kind of very you know it's
possible to phrase the argument form
possibility of consensus as as an
extension based proof you have to work a
little bit but not too hard but we can
actually make it easier by extending the
kinds of queries you support so for
example we can extend our proof to allow
a schedule starting from two gasps where
they're from a particular configuration
is their schedule in which some process
outputs a well we can also ask the
approver can ask the the protocol to
actually produce such a schedule a
variety of other things and so we can
actually extend a result like the
impossibility to include those kinds of
queries as well and finally we this is
just I've talked about this in terms of
proving possibility results we can also
do with a little bit of tweaking we can
show that covering arguments which we
use to prove space complexity lower
bounds and they talked a little bit
about that the bootcamp that we can also
use a similar approach to prove that the
space law or space lower bounds for case
that agreement can't be proved using its
extension based proofs which are
basically covering arguments hey thank
you very much
[Applause]
any questions between
I know that terminology is a little
daunting but it's it's actually pretty
if we kept it to a minimum it's actually
not that hard and if anybody wants to
talk to me about this some other point
or see some of the proof I'm happy to
show you so thanks a lot